the Cardassians are slowly returning to  social media following Kim's Paris  robbery ordeal and Rob is making a big  reveal Kylie was first to come back with  this throwback pic on Tuesday then early  Thursday morning kendall Jenner posted a  new Instagram it's this smiley shot of  the model rocking an oversized  heart-shaped fur jacket she captioned  the pic low key look then there's  Kourtney Kardashian's new tweet she took  a pic of a Bible verse it's all about  finding strength and joy on even the  toughest days which seems to be a slight  nod to what Kim is going through Rob  Kardashian has been active on Twitter to  retweeting his friends but he's also  sharing good news on the next all-new  episode of Rob and China I'm completely  like free of diabetes I guess like the  best news I heard in a like all year  literally